I want to tell you a little bit of a
story about Apache beam which is a
really exciting project which probably
some of you already have heard about
it's a very ambitious project and it's
quite a quite tough to squish it into 30
minutes but I try my best and also we
have the office hours afterwards and I'm
welcome to demo anything or answer your
questions and if you have any questions
please maybe also write them down so you
don't forget them yeah
so my name is Max I work on Apache beam
I'm a committed there and specifically
on the portability aspects which I will
touch at the end of my talk so I'd like
to know actually who has who has used
flink
or SPARC I could you please raise your
hand that's that's quite a lot of people
and who has used beam before or read
about it let's say okay that's also
fairly a fair amount of people and what
about Google Cloud dataflow for instance
okay that's interesting okay so I know
you already you're you're a bit familiar
in the space that's great so what but I
want to recap for those who who don't
know about beam yet so what is what is
the vision of beam it's a very ambitious
vision as I mentioned so we have a bunch
of SDKs and beam which basically allow
you to write data processing jobs we
have Java Python go scholar and sequel
and the way this works is that you write
your pipeline and then then you then
beam kind of figure out a way to using
various runners to execute your data
processing pipeline on top of various
backends and these backends are like
fling sums our Google Cloud SPARC and
some others more and so the important
key to understanding beam is that beam
sort of provides some building blocks
for
execution and has its own model but it's
not an execution engine that's what the
backends are for and so what is the the
beam way of doing things what is the
beam model so first of all and what is
remarkable is that it's unified batch
and stream model so that means you don't
have to switch to a different system or
a different API if you want to use
either bachelor streaming and I will
show you how that how that actually
works it's quite quite a nice concept
and yeah if you really think about
streams in terms of when you work with
beam then streaming is sort of the
default and batch is just a bounded
stream and everything else is unbounded
right and yeah so and beam you you
define your processing pipelines and
then obviously it's you apply
transformation in these pipelines and
they are massively paralyzed herbal and
so this is the concept of beam it's it's
for big data so just in case you didn't
know and yeah and one of the other
concepts that that's really innovative
in beam is the concept of event time and
which I will touch in a bit there's also
an excellent paper which sums this whole
model app if you're into papers
otherwise just listen to my talk and so
what does the beam API look like so it's
basically just in the beginning you you
set up your pipeline which is an acyclic
graph attack and this pipeline consists
of of transformations on P collections
so one of things to keep in mind when
you design your pipeline is that you you
you have a P collection you bootstrap
your P collection and you do apply on
the P collection and basically supply a
transform in and you end up again with a
P collection and then in you and you run
your pipeline so that's pretty simple so
let's start with
with defining our sources sources are
actually also just transforms in beam
which basically bootstrapped from the
pipeline object kind of wish I had
brought a laser pointer but maybe we can
use my mouse no I can't
so here we have in the previous slide I
showed you like this transformation from
input to output so but you can actually
have multiple because it's a dag you can
have parallel sources as here like we
have an input one where we read from a
from a text file then we have this in
memory kind of string collection there
and you can also read two Kafka and
they're a bunch of adapters you can
check it on the home page so that is
covered and then regally if you want to
understand transformations with Apache
beam you have to only pretty much only
understand two main concepts and if you
if you come from
MapReduce Hadoop world those of you who
do then you you know probably like the
MapReduce face and the shuffle in
between and that's pretty much what
so the MapReduce part is basically what
the pardhu is the parallel do and so it
takes an input element and transforms it
into an int into an output element so
just a simple example here we have the
strings given and we basically transform
them in key into key value pairs where
we assign a word count of one so does
the firm is the famous world count
example and that's basically your your
map face and then you do the the group
by which shuffles the data and groups
all the the same keys together with
their values so then you can actually
you could actually now do a pardhu again
and reduce these to sum up
[Music]
number of word occurrences yeah so
that's pretty much I mean if you know
these two then you can pretty much build
your pipelines very very flexible so how
does that look in in practice so I'm
using Java here for for these examples
and I hope that doesn't scare you too
much so we have we have our words here
loaded and if we want to do assign the
word counts as I showed you in the
previous slide we have this pardhu
transform and in the party who gets a
and do event function you can see it
takes it from string to Q value of
string integer and yeah so and you have
the process element function which is
called for every element and for the
group by key it's basically as simple as
just doing this group by key create a
transformation which will then give you
for every key it will give you so which
for every word it will give you an
iterable so basically list of integers
which you can then sum up and that's
basically i'm in terms of primitive
transforms and all you need to know for
the beginning so you can build some some
more cool stuff with this and one of the
things in beam that is also used heavily
is combined but it's actually just
composed of of this powder and group by
key transformation today I just showed
you so combined for example it basically
is like a shuffle and reduce and one
step so if you already have your key
value pairs your words your words and
your word occurrences then the combined
the combined per key basically and gives
you automatically groups and gives you
you can supply a function to some out to
sum up the results per key and you can
even do this whole like my
reduced MF shaffer reduce in one and
step if you define like a combine of and
which gives you more flexibility yeah
and I realized this has been already a
lot of code on the slide so I don't want
to give you more for now and there are
more transforms like Co group by key
which is a basically joint so you take
two inputs and merge them and then you
can yeah join and do a joints of all
kinds of sorts
there's also flatten which is basically
like a union you can there's a special
petition trans transformation and also
you can define your own that's that's
the beauty of the model there are even
more advanced concepts like side inputs
so which basically gives you a way to to
pre-compute
a data set that you receive in your
operator before that operator starts
processing data so that's really useful
if you train if you want to provide a
machine learning model for instance or
some like static input that you did you
know that you you can compute it upfront
and have that available everywhere and
yeah multiple outputs might be useful if
you want to divert your your your
computation afterwards they also state
and timers I'm not gonna go and just for
now so you might be wondering now didn't
he'd say in the beginning that beam was
about like unbounded data and streams
and all we did was like Map Reduce
that's like I mean that's kind of not
gonna work for streams if we have
infinite input actually am yes that's
true but since streams are unbounded by
nature we have to have some kind of
discretization of the stream and this is
done in in so called windows and these
windows basically yeah do a grouping in
terms of some criteria most of the time
it is actually according to time because
this is what we what we usually
interested in but it's it's quite
flexible and then because you can find
your own window function and then there
are triggers which basically decide when
when a window is complete or when
results from the window should be
emitted and yeah one of the really cool
new things that being brought was event
time and because time is very important
when you process data and usually and
you you have some sort of time stamp
assigned to your data but maybe it's not
explicit or you you just use assume the
time stamp is at the time when your data
arrives or so but in beam like this time
stamp is is explicitly represented in
every element I mean and if you have a
batch pipeline for example then it might
be just like at the fault timestamp or
so and you don't have to take care of it
and then there's this other cool concept
which is called the watermark the
watermark is basically a time stem that
is passed through the entire dag and it
indicates the current event time and
again most of the time you don't need to
worry about it but it's it's a really
cool way to be able to set the time
basically in the computation so I
realized this it's not clear to everyone
and I want to differentiate event time
from processing time first of all so
imagine this is like this is like a
computation and in that computation you
have some notion of processing time
which so this could be your clock on
your machine that which you run and that
processing time basically
umm.yeah passes from zero to 60 minutes
and mu you you have events arriving and
they have an event time which is on the
y-axis so a lot of times we assume that
event and processing time are the same
and that's like for the first three red
dots we have we have same like zero five
and ten
same process processing an event time
but in reality what happens is that you
you do some kind of computation and you
you for example you sum up use a score
so for every 10 minutes or so and you
just take what what comes what comes in
right and and and send that up but it
could be actually that you are you are
thinking you're at processing time 20
but actually you're ven time is ten so
that would actually mean you would be we
would be late and processing that data
and and similar similarly it could also
happen the other way around and beam
just gives you a means to to give credit
to that time distinction and that's
that's really cool so for those who have
maybe not understood this yet here's a
nice analogy so if you if you think
about think of Star Wars and and for
those of you who know it's Star Wars
know probably also that the episodes
from the storyline didn't appear in the
chronological order so first there was
like five four or five six and then one
two three and that's well if you want to
watch it from from the beginning to the
end the story and that's that's kind of
out of order right but it makes sense
because that's just that's just when
when the when the episodes appeared
right so you can think about about it
like this so processing time would be
the appearance as we know it of Star
Wars and event time would be the
episodes sorted like chronological to
the to the time in the movies actually
so with that knowledge now let's apply
our our knowledge about transformations
and time and windows and built like like
a more interesting but still simple
pipeline so I'm assuming I I have some
input and I want to I want to sum up
scores or some kind of integers on that
input
and yeah I'm doing it perky so it could
be user and the score for a game for
instance and yeah the way we typically
what what helps when you develop
pipelines and you want to leverage the
full power of beam is that you ask
yourself is for questions so what are
you trying to compute well I'm trying to
sum up integers perky makes sense then
then when actually then actually where
where are you doing that in event time
so here I'm defining just in front of
the the actual summation I'm defining
Windows of two minutes intervals and
these are fixed windows so there's a
different kind of windows there if you
don't do any one you it's a global
window which you which you would use for
batch and and then there's the fixed the
sliding and the precession window and
well these are pretty much I mean it
self-explanatory but the fixed ones
basically they create a new window every
two minutes and a sliding one basically
and has a size but also it has a sliding
interval where it moves like
continuously so the windows are
overlapping perky and the way to think
about is not that
there's a window and then there's
another window and then it's another
window now these can actually exist all
at the same time depending on what kind
of data arrives like I showed you in the
previous like here in the if we if we
have some element that it's late then
this might actually end up in a later
window but then the question is of
course we have all these windows we have
to admit we have to compute the exo
actual computation and emit some results
right and this is where our triggers
come in so the default trigger if you
don't specify anything is it's exactly
just this trigger at watermark so the
watermark I told you is like a time
stamp that is passed from
to sources to the sinks in a pipeline
and the watermarks basically advances
the event time but it also gives some
gives some flexibility of how fast how
quickly time advances and most of the
time this is actually based on a
heuristic because you and you can never
be sure whether like I mean if the way
the data arrives late or not but it
gives you much better control of of your
computation so yeah and there are also
other kind of triggers
so not only event time you can also do
it processing time based or based on
data that that arrives and yeah and so I
mentioned early and late so there's a
possibility also to to fire earlier so
in case you want really early results
already even even though the window is
not yet and at the default trigger at
the the watermark or even if if you have
something late arriving then you might
want to fire again when something right
and by default beam throws away the
entire window after it has computed a
result but it is also possible to
actually hold on to that window so you
can do like accumulating fired panes
which which will then give you the
possibility to read Because recompute
the entire result because you still have
all the data when when something arrives
late so I mentioned that we have
actually also other SDKs and not only
Java and I think that's really exciting
because it gives also people who don't
don't feel so comfortable with Java a
chance to play around with with beam and
if you compare the two api's that we
have
available here on the slide you see it's
actually quite similar I mean this the
syntax here with the pipe it's it's
maybe not exactly pythonic but it is
kind of like similar to what you get
would get in a shell and that's it's
kind of cool but otherwise you see the
concepts are the same so I'm sticking
now to to Python and I want to execute
now it's this pipeline so what I do is
basically I take one of take one of the
runners like the flink or the spark
Runner and I say like run pipeline so
yeah that's basically it
so what runners are actually out there
so there is a way to to directly execute
your pipeline for local testing for that
we have the direct runner and yeah then
there there's Apache flowing Apache
spark Sam's are apex and you can also
run on top of the Google cloud um and
there are a bunch of others work in
progress and I hope this just yeah we
will even support more runners on the
website there is there's actually a
compatibility matrix where you can see
which feature sets are supported by each
runner so I mean the the fling runner is
actually pretty much on par with the
Google cloud and and it supports the
whole model feature set but not off not
all of the other runners do that so
that's something it's a consideration to
take into account so actually I haven't
told you I haven't told you the whole
truth so so we have multiple runners and
we have these different SDKs but the
vision was always to have two a support
multiple SDKs right but the reality was
that um up until
sort of like a year ago basically only
Java pipelines worked because we had to
figure out a way to execute with all
these different SDKs right because all
of these SDKs can have like bison and
code in the in the language of the SDK
and how can we execute that with Java
right I mean sort of so sure we can spin
off a - like process inside a Java
function but this gets really tricky
like when when we have libraries and of
that sort and when we have want to have
like a like a proper environment that is
not you know that is consistently there
and we don't have that we don't have to
bring up every time so what can we do
it's simple right we have an runners we
have M languages so we just build like n
times M translation path right so we
have five runners for instance three
languages 15 translation path no problem
right well adds but it's a bit of a
problem actually because replicating is
logic for all these different languages
and renesis is a lot of work so what we
what the project did instead was work on
portability and what portability means
and that is basically like the fact that
the last missing piece of beam which is
already like very far but and actually
for for the fling runner it's it's now
it's now a supported feature but this is
very exciting and because it gives you
the opportunity to use any of the
supported SDKs and including libraries
and user-defined function and write
write a beam pipeline with it so to do
that we actually had to find some
language independent way to express
pipelines and that is called the runner
API
the runner API has basically
transformations from the pipeline and
which worship beckons which are maybe in
Java this old Java actually and they can
understand these these concepts fairly
easily but then they also these bits
like in the pardhu function where we
have Python code or our go code and Java
the Java beckons I really don't know
what to do with that so we have the XE
we have the FN the fun API which is
basically an abstraction to to execute
these these parts which the backends
don't understand so just a little
strange is a bit more so we have without
the portability we had basically like
SDK and runner all in the same language
and then we have these tasks running in
the backend and they are all like tied
to a single language with the
portability and it's a it's a little bit
more complicated but it works really
elegantly so we have the SDK in a
language of our choice then we actually
have the job API which managed banishes
the whole job submission to the cluster
so in the past you had to kind of know
whether you're using spark or fleeing
you had to you know use their way of
submitting stuff to the cluster but now
there is a beam drop server which takes
your your beam pipeline and and because
it's in this runner API the runner can
then go ahead and submit this job to the
to the backend and whenever the backend
sees like stuff in the pipeline that it
doesn't understand and for example a map
- function then it brings up like a
Python - container which we call the SDK
harness and sends data to that container
the container processes it and sends it
back to the to the backend so and that
yeah that is that works for all kinds of
transformations in beam including side
input and state yeah so that's a really
really elegant way to solve this so we
don't need to have this runners times
SDK it is all these execution paths we
just need to implement the SDKs which we
already have and we we need the runners
to to be able to support these portable
jobs and then we need to also only once
for each language we needn't implement
these SDK harnesses so I mentioned the
flink Runner is like the first
open-source Runner which supports this
new way of execution this is this
doesn't mean you cannot try out beam
today with with another back-end it's
just that we have we are sort of edition
phase where we have the old Java way of
executing in the open source and then
the cross the potentially also cross
language part of a way of of executing
jobs so and that's that's really
exciting if I think about it that we
will be able to execute also be Python
and Java and beam pipelines in the same
like job so so that's potentially a use
case the future use case there's some
overhead to it of course because we have
to send data to to these containers
which involves some like serialization
we have we did some measure measurement
and it was between like five and ten
percent overhead but actually it could
be it could also be zero it really
depends on your pipeline and I think
it's definitely worth the trade-off that
said there will also be a way to still
directly execute like for example pure
Java pipeline for people who really want
to leverage like all the all the
performance and not go through that
portable way
yeah so I was gonna I was gonna show you
a demo but I feel like if I try to set
this up now I probably run into a time
problem and I would like to defer this
to the office hours
unless somebody really wants to see that
see I'm just running you have to take my
word for it for now
so how can you get involved or if you
want to learn more about beam so the
website of course is great because it
has really good documentation and
examples how to write beam pipelines
then there are also this mailing list
and I'm on this and if you yeah if you
write them write an email you can be
sure to receive some some response from
all the from from the other committers
and other users and there's also great
slack channel which maybe you get even a
faster response you can follow an apache
beam on twitter you can follow me i'm
twitter work on this with this weird
handles start legenda and that's it
thank you
[Applause]
hi can you say a little bit more about
how the watermark heuristic works yeah
so let me go back to so so in in your
sources when you read for example from
Kafka or pops up or whatever there
there's a way to to omit watermarks and
a lot of sources they actually they take
for example the last elements in the
last minute and they omit the minimum
for example of the time stem that
they've seen so far so that way they
they make sure that they don't advance
the watermark too quickly so because if
there's a there's a time stamp which is
much much later already then in time
then the watermark would be moved too
far forward in time and then new
elements might be considered late so
this is one one option that horses use
also other sources and they use just the
processing time which is also an option
and yeah I think these are the most
common two ways of omitting watermarks
yeah the watermark basically tracks
tracks the real-time whatever you
consider real-time it doesn't have to be
necessarily the time on your machine but
it's basically I mean it needs to make
progress if it doesn't make progress
then basically execution halts and yeah
nothing is computed anymore but it's
yeah it's possible assistance he here
that it is temporarily sort of lagging
behind and then catching up again
you